we don't care if you're naughty or nice
you deserve our best gadget gift advice
do we start the caroling now have you
heard my voice I think that would ruin
everybody's holiday you know what else
ruins the holidays terrible gadget gifts
so true and that's why we're here all
year long the two of us test tech
products so we made a list of stuff we'd
actually buy ourselves and in some cases
already have that means we have some
pics that are your typical gadget gifts
like a printer no the Epson 80 25 50 eco
tank isn't for the person you hate
instead it's the printer that every
family should have see it kills the ink
cartridge instead of those overpriced
pieces of plastic that house ink the
printer has tanks that can hold years of
that stuff and when you run out you
refill it with more affordable ink you
may not think about getting someone a
camera lens either but the DxO one was
one of my favorite gadgets of the year
and it's every instagramers dream the
twenty point two megapixel camera plugs
into the base of an iphone five or six
which then serves as the viewfinder and
Central Command you get DSLR style
images including stunning night shots
and depth of field effects that the
iPhones own camera can't match of course
wearable tech is supposed to be the next
big thing but if all the smartwatches we
tested this year only the Apple watch
stuck to our wrists it still isn't for
everyone but if you're interested in
getting email and text notifications on
your wrist and tracking your fitness the
Apple watch sport is the best SmartWatch
you can buy just remember you need the
iPhone for it to work or you can wear
something that lets you peer into the
future
seriously virtual reality is gonna take
off in 2016 and with the Samsung gear VR
you'll be ready for it
strap your Samsung phone inside and
you'll enter a 360-degree universe with
improved sensors in over 100 apps the
gear VR offers a totally immersive
experience
you must try and of course we didn't
forget about the kids wait do I count as
a kid
no but this one is just as fun for
adults as it is for kids little bits is
an electronics building kit for the
smartphone age with the new gizmos and
gadgets kit you get motors power sources
even wireless transmitters follow along
with the different project diagrams and
you can make everything from a two-wheel
flipping robot to a remote-control car
sure you could build a robot but why not
adopt one from a galaxy far far away
bb-8 is what you want rolling around you
can control the round sidekick from this
year's Star Wars via a smartphone app or
by yelling commands just watch out while
his head stays upright he zooms by at
five miles per hour we have lots more
pics in our full gadget guide at wsj.com
and we promise our taste in gadgets is
way better than Joanna's taste in
holiday sweaters hey can someone get us
some eggnog and a latke